mcafee dead spanish prison suicide
i guess it's true i guess it is true
he did say if i recall correctly that he
did not plan to kill himself
but maybe he did and he said it
let's see here john mcafee
two hours ago his extradition was
approved
and now he has been found dead in a
spanish prison
it is a new york post report and you
know the new york post is
is essentially fox news um people may or
may not know that
antivirus software pioneer john mcafee
dead after prison suicide antivirus
software tycoon john mcafee died by an
apparent suicide in a spanish jail cell
wednesday evening
hours after reports surfaced that he
would be extradited to face federal
charges in the u.s
according to local media the eccentric
tech entrepreneur was arrested in
october
and was awaiting extradition when he was
found dead police sources told the
newspaper el pais that's the spanish
newspaper the newspaper reported mcafee
was pulled from his cell in barcelona
and police are investigating the
circumstances around his death
mcafee was hit with a 10-count
indictment earlier on wednesday the
spanish high court had agreed to
extradite mcafee
who has been charged with a number of
federal
financial crimes in two districts in the
united states
also charged in a separate indictment in
manhattan federal
court in march for a pump and dump
scheme involving kryptos
that is everything that is known so far
um
daily beast i'm told also has it
let's see here
mcafee dead in spanish prison now do
they just quote the new york post
uh no spanish newspaper el mundo
let's take a look at that oh no
i guess i gotta accept ads here
ads and cookies
everything points to what could be
treated as a death by suicide
prison authorities assure us
prison authorities have confirmed that
the american magnate john mcafee
creator of the famous antivirus of his
own name
has been found dead in his cell which he
occupied in the first module of the
centro penitenciario de bryant's dos
he was 75 years old this morning
the national audience nacional
finally gave the go-ahead to extradite
mcafee to the united states
wow that is uh i mean listen
i think he had recently said he was not
going to be killing himself
but he did not strike me as a guy that
was well so i don't know what to make of
it
i don't know what to make of it but it
is something
certainly we will be uh looking into